Buenas tardes El Congreso de Perú
poserga nuevamente el debate porque no
existe el consenso de los legisladores
para aprobar la reforma del adelanto de
las elecciones mientras la bancadas
discuten algunos congresistas denuncian
que existe un intento encubierto de
reelección en el proyecto la congresista
sucelpa es afirma que el borrador de la
norma tal como está escrita Establece
que los congresistas están habilitados
para postular al parlamento nuevamente
para ella y para muchos legisladores
Esto no es correcto es por eso que han
anunciado que van a votar en contra de
la iniciativa de otro lado los
congresistas de izquierda que exigen la
convocatoria a una asamblea
Constituyente también señalan que no
están de acuerdo y van a votar en contra
del proyecto no se sabe cuánto más
puedas extenderse el plazo esto porque
el congreso el presidente del Congreso
ha extendido la realización de la
legislatura y tal como están las cosas
señalan que quizás la sesión de mañana a
las once se inicia y culmine sin
acuerdos y Francisco Cuál es ahora la
reacción del gobierno de la presidenta
de nahuel Duarte
la posición del gobierno de la
presidenta Dina boluartes de calma y
expectativa al respecto del Primer
Ministro Alberto dotárola ha dicho que
el poder ejecutivo se encuentra a la
espera de la decisión que adopte el
parlamento para sacar al Perú de esta
crisis política con una salida
democrática Mientras tanto las protestas
y los bloqueos continúan en las últimas
horas la superintendencia de saneamiento
alertado que comunidades indígenas de
cinco regiones del Perú se encuentran en
riesgo de quedarse sin agua potable
debido precisamente a las protestas y a
los bloqueos de las carreteras